bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver à la une de ce tabou regarde
ce soir des colères française à peine
des consignes et le pays est à nouveau
en proie à la violence la manifestation
des soignants à paris a dégénéré on a vu
à nouveau des casseurs infiltrés les
cortèges mais pas seulement
une infirmière a perdu ses nerfs alors
est-ce que les black blocs peuvent
entraîner d'autres publics dans leur
sillage comme on l'avait vu au moment dé
gilet jaune
est ce qu'une manifestation qui se
termine bien une manifestation paisible
est possible dans le pays
on en débat dans un instant avec nos
invités elle souffrait déjà d'isolement
avant la crise sanitaire comment les
personnes handicapées ont elles vécu le
confinement nervosité stress anxiété
surtout lorsque son emploi est en jeu on
va faire un bilan complet avec la
ministre en charge de ce dossier
sophie calle del est notre invité ce
soir enfin le jour d'après nouvel
épisode de notre série d'entretiens sur
la praye coronavirus ce soit lui muni t
comment fonctionne notre système
immunitaire pourquoi certains malades
sont immunisés et pas d'autres le
professeur jean claude baye le
professeur à l'hôpital necker a répondu
à nos questions voilà donc pour le
programme vous savez tous ces partis à
sec sévère
on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
on les avait presque oublié ces images
de manifestations qui dégénèrent elle
nous saute à nouveau au visage après 56
jours de confinement crs contre de
casseurs et au milieu des soignants
prison d'otages images de l'esplanade
des invalides hier après midi à deux pas
de l'assemblée nationale et images qui
en rappelle beaucoup d'autres le monde
d'après ressemble trait pour trait au
monde d'avant bonsoir bruno qu est l on
soit et merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député la république en marche de leur
et vous dialoguez ce soir avec adrie
saïd youcef bonsoir ravi de vous
retrouver vous êtes président de
l'institut léonard de vinci spécialiste
des questions de sécurité intérieure je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
mais d'abord le roccat le regard de
blacko comme tous les soirs si j'ai bien
compris c'est parti que nous arrive-t-il
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien tout
sourire bonsoir à tous deux fois ben si
j'ai bien compris myriam l'immense
majorité des français et contre le
recours à la violence par les analystes
enfin quand on dit l'immense majorité
des français ça veut aussi dire que
c'est pas le cas de tous les français
donc
souvenez vous en décembre 2010 vite il y
avait eu le saccage de l'arc de triomphe
à l'issue d'un premier rassemblement le
gilet jaune et donc on avait fait un
sondage pour tenter de savoir ce que les
français pensaient de de ce déchaînement
de violence alors je vous montre le
résultat qui se lit en deux temps vous
allez voir sur la gauche il ya un gros
camembert ou on voit que 85% des
français sont contre le recours à la
violence
il ya la can 15% qui eux disent qu'ils
sont pour 15% ça fait quand même
quelques millions de français très très
en colère après quand on regarde dans le
détail on voit que les partisans de la
violence sont surtout situés aux
extrêmes 6 27% pour le rassemblement
national 22 % pour l efi donc finalement
c'est pas par rapport à la moyenne au
nombre de 15 c'est vraiment de
deux pointes remarquable donc ce n'est
pas si étonnant que miner grand champ
mis le pen n'est jamais vraiment
officiellement ou vraiment condamner la
violence de les gilets jaunes il avait
toujours une autre explication qui
préférait une dans le cas de marine le
pen s'était dire que cette violence
était celle des black blocks donc la
donne interwiew à sud radio on voit ces
déclarations alors mélenchon de son côté
lui là il dédouanait les gilets jaunes
en dix ans mais dans tout ça c'est la
faute des policiers il avait même prêté
de de barbares à l'occasion bon il ya
quand même un truc sur lequel tous les
deux étaient d'accord c'était pour dire
que les manifestants n'étaient pas
responsables de la violence tout ça
c'était la faute du gouvernement bâlois
y ait un autre plus tard ça n'a pas
vraiment changé donc ni mélenchon ni
marine la peine ne condamne la violence
sauf quand ça les arrange par exemple
quand on parle à marine le pen des
violences policières
c'est à peine s'ils ont entendu parler
un don que pas mal de policiers et votre
assemblée nationale on ne sait pas trop
son intérêt quand on lui demande elle
dit noreau je pense que ça n'existe pas
vraiment ces violences policières et
puis côté insoumis c'est bien sûr la
réaction inverse
et quand par exemple une infirmière
callas des crs et qu'elle se fait
interpeller la mathilde de panneaux la
députée insoumis a tendance à lui
trouver des circonstances atténuantes en
écoute je pense qu'en face de policiers
que ce sont eux équipés une jeune femme
qui lance une femme qui lancent des
petites pierres ça ne justifie pas une
interpellation aussi violente que celle
que nous voyons sur les vidéos alors
bien sûr pour conclure on serait tenté
de mettre tout sur le dos de mélenchon
et le pen
un peu comme d'habitude doit juste
rappeler un truc c'est que mélenchon le
pen quand il se présente à la
présidentielle à eux deux ils ont fait
40 % des voix au premier tour et que
législatives et ils ont obtenu à deux
que 4 % des sièges de députés donc
peut-être que quand l'opposition la
colère peut pas s'exprimer dans les
institutions elles s'expriment en dehors
dans la rue par exemple
c'est une piste merci et vous restez
avec nous stéphane vous pouvez
intervenir quand vous le voulez je vais
commencer avec voudrez saïd youcef à
chaque fois dans ces images on nous
explique parce qu'elles sont pas
nouvelles depuis 2016 c'est comme si on
s'était habitué que les black blocks que
les ultras que les casseurs sont
dissimulés dans
finalement il arrive à à resurgir d'une
certaine façon en fin de cortège
et ça dégénère pourquoi marche pas à
démanteler ces black bloc et la question
du démantèlement elle se pose
effectivement dans un second sens s'ils
sont dans un second temps par ton s'ils
sont constitués en association
là pour le coup on est en manifestations
et en manifestation vient qui veut venir
puisque la manifestation est une liberté
constitutionnellement garantis à partir
de ce moment là la puissance publique al
organise une présence ce qu'on appelle
en maintien de l'ordre police
administrative avec des crs et des
gendarmes mobiles pour assurer la
sécurité de la manifestation
et mieux vaut avoir un désordre qui est
un désordre acceptable plutôt qu'une
charge contre des manifestants et contre
des casseurs qui pourrait faire des
blessés voire des morts pourquoi
n'arriva pas en amont à faire en sorte
qu'il ne s'infiltre pas la tentative a
échoué puisque c'était souvenez-vous de
cette loi dit la loi anti-casseurs avec
cette interdiction administrative de
manifester souvenez vous on avait parlé
sur ce plateau ailleurs le conseil
constitutionnel a retoqué cette
disposition au motif que ben c'est une
libertés constitutionnellement garantis
qu'il n'appartenait pas à l'autorité
administrative de la bride et mais
plutôt à l'autorité judiciaire et par
conséquent un individu même qui est
fiché pour justement être reconnu pour
être un casseur a le droit de venir à
partir de ce moment il ne casse pas et
d'avoir participé à une manifestation
pour remettre les choses en place qui
sont vraiment les casseurs ont l'etrat
gauche c'est l'ultra gauche les antifas
les à dist et aujourd'hui on ya aussi
des ultras jaune qui sont venus
s'ajouter on l'a vu à la manifestation
avec les personnels soignants on a vu
aussi des ultras jaune se joindre
effectivement à ces casseurs qui
constituent des black blocs puisque
black book est une technique vous
attendez à sarrebruck est elle pour vous
vous avez vous même été victime de
violences un pendant le mouvement d'aidé
gilet jaune
on a ici est souvent sur ce plateau avec
vous essayez de comprendre ce qui se
passait dans la rue ça recommence après
56 jours de confinement vous a surpris
pas plus que ça
pendant le confinement la société n'a
pas réglé tous ses mots si je peux me
permettre tous les déséquilibres
institutionnels politiques démocratiques
que l'on connaît depuis des décennies
n'ont pas été effacés d'un trait de
plume surpris pas plus que ça une
nouvelle fois parce que parce qu'il ya
une violence qui est là que je suis une
partie de la population il ya une
violence aussi kevin véhiculée par
certains discours compris de certains de
mes collègues
vous avez repéré vous les avez montré
l'image tout à l'heure ils sont parfois
enclin à légitimer par anticipation
certaines formes de violence dans la
population pour mieux la dénoncer après
dans les réactions qui force de leurs
pourrait avoir pour justement les faire
régner l'ordre public tout ça et il
attise la violence
bien sûr je pense qu'ils attisent la
violence et je parlais quoi je n'ai
clairement je pense des députés français
insoumise qui errent en pénétrer
quasiment par effraction dans le
commissariat du 7ème arrondissement pour
si on les écoute à les libérer cette
femme qui avait commis des faits qui ont
été montrés à l'image par toutes parts
par toutes les rares marlène target ce
que je pense à ces députés qui toujours
ceints de leur écharpe moi je veux dire
je ne mets jamais mon écharpe
parce que je ne veux pas être comparé
mes collègues de la france est soumise
je trouve qu'on est dans une totale
dérive de l'exercice du mandat de
parlementaire
nous représentants la nation dans son
ensemble la république et la république
c'est pas dire aux gens révélé vous
comme monsieur mélenchon l'a fait lors
de son discours des voeux ne respectait
pas des institutions et allez-y vous
pouvez taper du flic c'est pas grave on
vous soutiendra
non mais je me pose la question je pense
que ce n'est pas leur rôle je pense que
ce n'est pas leur rôle d'encourager les
gens à être violents on va venir
maintenant sur les sur les solutions
parlait de cette loi anti casseurs c'est
vrai qu'elle a été en partie retoqué par
le conseil constitutionnel
non parce qu'il réclame des mesures
fortes et qui a été votée ça ne va pas
c'est pas que ça ne marche pas c'est que
la jurisprudence constitutionnelle en
référentiel entre guillemets le bloc de
constitutionnalité ou sainte lucie et
les déclaration de 1789
depuis c'est une décision des années 70
dont j'oublie la date exacte mais qui
étend le champ de l'investigation du
conseil constitutionnel tout ça donne
nous interrogé aussi sur la manière dont
on appréhende tout cela justement on a
bien pris je ne peux rien faire je pense
qu'on légifère dans la temporalité je
pense qu'on légifère mal
on rédige hiver on légifère souvent en
réaction à des événements souvent
dramatiques et en vigie faire aussi sans
anticiper jeu
la doctrine et la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel que je pense
pour être pourrai mieux travailler tout
cela il y a deux éléments d'abord je
pense que en termes de 2,2 si je regarde
les violences pour ce cas les exactions
qui ont été commises
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de dégradations à
l'exception de ces quelques voitures
retournées y compris j'ai une pensée
pour le propriétaire de la voiture qui
est un rien une personnes avec handicap
dans la voiture a été complètement
retourné sur la voie publique ensuite il
ya un vrai sujet c'est l'application des
peines cirque lorsqu un moment donné
vous avez des individus qui commettent
des exactions et des violences contre
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
ça constitue une circonstance aggravante
quelle est la réaction finalement de
l'autorité judiciaire ou du juge pénal
et basse à cette question elle est
importante parce que selon qu'elle est
forte ou qu'elle est moins forte ou
qu'elle est totalement absente et à une
certaine forme d'impunité et puis
derrière peut-être de récidive est au
fond aujourd'hui on voit bien que la
violence elle s'exprime sur la voie
publique en marge des manifestations
puisque dans les slogans deux
manifestations nous rappelle que la
manifestation
c'est un grand moment qui va être un
moment de bonheur où je reprend la
formule du conseil constitutionnel les
gens les nos concitoyens viennent
exprimer des idées des opinions commune
et on n'en est plus là
alors moi j'ai pas vu énormément de
casse mais j'ai eu une certaine forme de
lassitude chez les français qui consiste
à dire on en a marre de la casse
on veut que les personnels soignants
manifeste et on veut que les personnels
soignants obtiennent de crise économique
et sociale
et après pour les commerçants déjà un
mouvement déchiré je voudrais que l'on
reste un peu sur cette question des
solutions face aux as et groupuscule
d'ultra qui cherche la violence avant de
parler de ce qui s'est passé avec cette
infirmière est ce que au fond c'est
mouvement d'ultra sont en train
d'essaimer à d'autres publics bonsoir
géraldine woessner merci d'être avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes
chroniqueuse dans cette émission
journaliste au point alors on se doute
bien que la france n'est pas la seule à
faire face à ce problème des black
blocks
comment ça se passe chez nos voisins il
n'y a pas de système parfait
mais il ya des doctrines différentes
dont la france d'ailleurs et c'est un
peu de s'inspirer en allemagne par
exemple
cette doctrine est inscrite dans le
droit c'est la désescalade ça consistait
à éviter autant que possible les
affrontements en amont des
manifestations avec la mobilisation des
services de renseignement celle d'agents
formés au dialogue avec les manifestants
la police a l'obligation de coopérer et
de communiquer avec eux c'est
fondamental la danse dans un pays qui a
une culture forte de dialogue social la
suède est la même approche avec des
officiers de dialogue qu'on envoie
désamorcer les conflits
la belgique également les pays bas et
dans ces pays l'armement des forces de
l'ordre est aussi plus léger qu'un pas
ou très peu de lanceurs de balles de
défense pas de grenades de
désencerclement on va privilégier les
bâtons défense canons à eau des
lacrymogènes
en grande bretagne la police de
proximité est aussi mise en valeur ce
qui permet même s'il ya des violences de
désamorcer les tensions
merci beaucoup géraldine des armées à
tous surtout pas mais l bd non mais
ouanna
vous savez les gens qui ont manifesté
c'est un fermier ou d'autres sont en
totale rupture dans ce que tout citoyen
doit espérer ou attendre du champ
démocratique
la classe politique a une immense
responsabilité dans la situation depuis
des comptes en pas depuis deux 2 ans ou
cinq ans je pense qu'on a vraiment une
crise profonde vers laquelle personne ne
s'est jamais vraiment attaquer mais à
part le président de la république avait
posé le bon diagnostic en se portant
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
disant certain nombre de choses qui
n'avaient jamais été exprimées ces
femmes et ces hommes aujourd'hui on leur
explique que je t'ai un bout de bitume
sur les policiers c'est un acte normal
dans le cadre d'une manifestation
vous avez des élus qui font ça vous avez
des chroniqueurs qui font ça vous avez
des personnes
institutionnellement installés sur les
réseaux sociaux sur certaines chaînes
concurrentes de la vôtre qui légitime
dans leur discours ces actes et ça c'est
insupportable c'est insupportable vous
avez mangé des enfants je veux dire il
parfois ils me disent mais qu'est ce que
vous foutez comment comment ça
fonctionne une société démocratique
quand on nous explique à la télé que ce
n'est pas grave d'utiliser
du mobilier urbain pour taper sur du
policier alors on va la voir cette image
puisque vous avez largement amorcée
amorcé la question il s'agirait donc
d'une infirmière qui et bascule dans la
violence
on va la voir la voici lançant des pavés
aux forces de l'ordre
ça s'est passé hier et vous voyez les
gestes qu'ils l'accompagnent sur
l'esplanade des invalides à paris elle a
passé la nuit et une partie de la
journée un haut commissariat du 7ème
arrondissement après une interpellation
musclée
saïd bardon et madre ça y est qu'est ce
qui se passe là à votre avis est ce que
c'est c'est black block qui au fond
arrive à essaimer c'est un dérapage il
faut pas en donner trop d'importance
ou alors on bascule à autre chose moi je
pense un peu les deux d'abord c'est un
dérapage qu'il faut relever et
conviendra de six ans la main une
infraction c'est un délit puisque par
ailleurs elle est quand même
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
hospitalière donc à l callas même si
c'est des petits projectiles des
collègues et et dans le même temps
j'entends ce qu'a dit son avocat le elle
a craqué j'ai craqué bon mais c'est
toute la difficulté c est la
jurisprudence administrative elle est
formel là dedans
les zélés les manifestants doivent se
désolidariser de groupes de casseurs
pourquoi parce que d'abord quand ils
sont la cible d'opérations de police
judiciaire et sur les premiers ciblés
parce que il ne se faufile pas comme les
questeurs et de ils sont
instrumentalisés par les par les
casseurs et on peut considérer aussi
elle n'a pas d'antécédents cette femme
on peut considérer d'une certaine
manière qu'elles étaient
instrumentalisés par les casseurs il est
une cible parfaite je vais vous dire
pourquoi pascal et une blouse blanche
allez une blouse blanche et c'est
excellent pour les casseurs et
d'ailleurs ce qu'on retient c'est
l'interpellation de sept femmes avec une
blouse blanche et qu'est ce qu'on a dit
mais c'est à personne les soigneurs
regarder comment traiter personnel
soignant en terme d'image politique en
termes de communication politique c'est
assez c'est un bon coureur voit les
organisations en même temps renault qui
est elle
il ya quand même une question certes
c'est un cas isolé
c'est la seule soignante à avoir au fond
enfreint la loi en jetant des pavés et
en s'affrontant directement avec les
forces de l'ordre est ce que vous
craignez une forme de contagion
d'autres publics doit on doit être
attentif
on doit être attentif à ce précédent qui
est désormais créer moi je peux
comprendre que psychologiquement un
moment on est un sujet que l'on craque
je peux tout comprendre être condamné
pour vous cette femme là ne doit pas
être félicités elle ne doit pas être
posé en héros comme l'ont fait les mêmes
collègues que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
elle ne doit pas être encouragé réitéré
elle doit comprendre que toutes ces
revendications légitimes qui sont
légitimes qu'on peut comprendre on a
fait exactement que dans les temps se
trouvait qu'on en fait une victime
j'ai pas dis vous je dis juste que
certaines certains élus certains partis
au principal la france et insoumise
tente de récupérer explique que c'est la
violence policière dont elle a fait
l'objet qui l'écouté de ce que son
avocat lui a dit ce jeudi mais aussi
musclé moi je suis passé quasiment au
même moment sur l'esplanade des
invalides n'était pas de tout repos non
plus pour les forces de l'autre faut pas
inverser la charge de la responsabilité
de l'événement
on a des forces de l'ordre dont on
disait en fin de semaine dernière qu'il
fallait les désarmer on a des forces de
lampes qui depuis deux ans sont soumises
quasi quotidiennement à des pressions et
des violences à des insultes à des
attaques alors que l'on roule c'est le
respect de l'ordre public alors sur la
sécurité qui est notre première liberté
c'est intéressant parce que je tenais ce
soir à ce qu'on ait un point de
comparaison avec nos voisins européenne
géraldine est toujours avec nos jeunes
comment comment ça se passait les moins
à l'offensive
la police ailleurs mais disons que la
police française elle et j'ai le
sentiment dans un entre-deux faut pas
oublier que pendant des années notre
doctrine c'était de protéger les gens de
protéger la liberté de manifester et
palais bien donc notre police est elle
restée à distance d'autres pays alors
nous prenait vraiment pour modèle
jusqu'à ce que le profil on l'a dit des
manifestants change l'ultra-gauche
défilé en queue de cortège autrefois
elle arrive maintenant en tête parfois
avec un mode d'expression plus violents
les cortèges sont plus d'un seul bloc
d'assez un agrégat de groupes
hétérogènes donc notre doctrine a évolué
ces deux dernières années pour être
capable d'écarter les plus radicaux et
elle vient au contact mais elle le fait
pendant la manifestation et sans ce
préalable dont on parlait tout à l'heure
de dialogue de confiance instauré avec
les manifestants ce qui fait que souvent
d'un certain vont se solidariser avec la
personne interpellée avec le casseur et
ça dégénère en allemagne
bah on n'intervient pas pendant que ça
se passe mais à la fin de la
manifestation salies limite évidemment
les dommages collatéraux et cela dit
faut aussi voir les contextes de moyens
d'abord la police allemande elle est
bien mieux dotés que la police française
et les plus nombreux sur le terrain
mieux former deux ans de formation
contre un an chez nous et la réponse
pénale
quand des casseurs sont arrêtés et
nettement plus ferme enfin repréciser
nulle part on ne peut rien contre des
des manifestants qui ont envie d'en
découdre
il ya déjà des modèles sur lesquels
s'appuyer ah oui je pense que nos
voisins jeu je partage complètement ce
qui vient d'être dit le modèle allemand
est un bon modèle la difficulté avec
notre modèle c'est au-delà effectivement
d'une police sécurité publique est sous
doté notamment sur des désuet fm des
unités de forces mobiles on à l'autre
difficulté c'est celle ce qui vient des
dit je vais peut-être paraphraser mais
j'y vais quand même c'est d'avoir ces
dont on a plus d'organisation avec des
services d'ordre terre que vous ne
dialoguer plus lorsque âme vous vous
avez là manifestants mais pas tant de
bien les syndicats vous avez d'autres
manifestations ou lorsque vous déposez
votre déclaration vous impose c'est la
loi qui vous impose d'avoir un service
d'ordre d'assurer la sécurité de votre
votre manifestation
et quant à un moment donné vous avez une
simple lettre qu arrive sur le bureau du
préfet de police et qui vous dit samedi
je suis là je fais mon trajet de la lah
et vous savez même pas qui c'est parce
que la loi globalement aujourd'hui est
là elle a modifié le régime de
déclaration des ddd demande de
manifestation et ben vous êtes devant
une vraie difficulté et le dialogue qui
s'instaure avec des organisateurs
responsables pas avec des prête-noms qui
déclarent une manifestation pour
permettre à d'autres de venir commettre
des exactions et toute la difficulté
aujourd'hui elle est de repenser
finalement une manifestation mais qui se
déroule en deux temps la manifestation
née sur la police administrative
gendarmes mobiles et crs pour assurer la
sécurité de la manifestation
et puis un deuxième temps de
manifestations dans police judiciaire et
là ce sont les bras avec les braves eh
ben les brigades de répression de
l'action violente qui eux vont plutôt
intervenir en police judiciaire pour à
les appréhender
quelquefois avec le lanceur de balles de
défense et les dégâts que cela cause à
les interpeller les fauteurs de troubles
cet effet mme daka ce qu'ils voulaient
intervenir et je pense vous vous
interrogez bruno keitel moi je me
faisais la réflexion que vous écoutant
que vous aviez basse et le sujet
beaucoup focalisé speg la boxe mais ça
finit par donner le sentiment que ils
sont à l'origine de tout gênant c'est
que si on savait la maîtrise et de s'en
débarrasser sa disparaîtrait il semble
que le mouvement des gilet jaune à
prouver quelque chose de très différent
que d'une part au mal et à la violence
nous avons été très longtemps soutenu
par les français donc la violence est
acceptée par un article d'opinion
on a vu que cette violence pendant qu'on
compte diabolise elle a aussi permis
d'obtenir des gains importants vis-à-vis
du gouvernement que sans la violence on
n'aurait pas obtenu donc cette manière
de diaboliser la violence et de la
restreindre black blocks donc c'est
celle là il ne l'a pas fait puisqu'il a
dit qu'elle était allée profondes et
anciennes
c'est pas bien violence permet aux non
mais les conquêtes temps et dans
l'histoire effectivement la violence
après on a même coupé des têtes un jour
elle m'est
j'ai pas j'ai pas du tout indiquée ou
alors je me suis mal exprimé que ce
qu'il fallait centre concentrer le débat
sur les black blocks on les a vu
apparaître grosso modo sur la loi une
connerie travail les premières violences
sont arrivés en 2016 vous l'évoquiez
tout à l'heure mais j'étais jeune
c'était une sacrée mosaïque je les ai
fait référence aux violences donc j'ai
pu être victimes j'ai fait qu'un 0.3 à
chaque fois une demi journée je peux
vous dire qu'il y ait des gens
d'horizons divers qui étaient réunis
uniquement par le chasuble jaune auquel
vous faites référence dans leur destin
leur histoire personnelle est haute
c'était une vraie mosaïque se
représenter la france finalement puisque
effectivement ça a été soutenue mais
mais maintenant moi je prends on a une
société démocratique en crise la moitié
des français au mieux ne vote pas ne
votent plus les deux tiers des français
ne croient plus aux élus nous sommes
tous pourris par définition on a le
monde syndical qui est complètement
sclérosée vous avez des permanents
syndicaux qui n'ont pas connu une chaîne
de montage en usine depuis 25 ou 30 ans
ça tombe bien il ya une personnalité qui
nous attend déterminée elle a sûrement
vous écoutez attentivement mes mandats
dans le temps pour les élus mais si on
pouvait l'appliquer aussi aux
représentants syndicaux je pense que ça
leur permettrait aussi de régénérer à la
fois leur doctrine et leur
fonctionnement bonsoir
céline verzeletti bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes secrétaire
confédérale de la cgt et vous avez
soutenu celle qui se prénomme farida
donc cette infirmière qui a été
interpellé puis placé en garde à vue au
commissariat de du 7e arrondissement à
paris
vous avez donc décidé de soutenir une
personne qui sait les images parlent
d'elles-mêmes commet une infraction pour
quelles raisons alors bien évidemment
que nous soutenons cette infirmière
comme nous soutenons toutes les victimes
qui donnait la sensation des jets des
pavés sur les forces de l'ordre
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal alors
elle l'a expliqué ana
elle n'a pas nié certains faits elle a
dit que oui elle avait craqué que ce
qu'il avait mis excessivement en colère
c'était justement le l'intervention
disproportionnée des forces de police en
train de manifestations et je peux en
attester puisque j'y étais aussi nous
sommes arrivés de manière tout à fait
pacifique et très nombreux et très
nombreuses sur la place des invalides et
à ce moment là pas de suite maintenant
lesquels elle est plus massif et que
vous le reconnaissez vous trouvez ça
justifier qu'elle ait fait l'objet d'une
interpellation d'une arrestation donc
alors non l'interpellation nous la
contestons parce que nous estimons que
l'interpellation est particulièrement
violente je ne sais pas si vous avez vu
aussi les images mais nous nous pensons
je le pense que l'on doit pouvoir
interpeller des personnes sans être
aussi violent entraîné une femme par les
cheveux
la blu qui se mettre à quatre sur elle a
bloqué là quand une côte cassée il faut
le dire si on ne sait pas en france
interpeller des personnes sans être
violent c'est un véritable problème
avait été un sujet que nous dénonçons
d'ailleurs depuis un certain temps le
défenseur des droits le dénonce aussi on
doit pouvoir quand même interpeller les
personnes dans ce pays sans être violent
et sans blesser les personnes il suffit
il ya des techniques des pratiques
professionnelles qui doivent permettre
et qui permettent normalement justement
de pouvoir en effet interpellé une
personne s'il a commis un délit de
manière non-violente donc déjà nous
dénonçons en effet la manière dont cette
infirmière a été interpellée elle a été
traînée par terre a tiré par les cheveux
quatre policiers étaient sur elle les
genoux sur elle elle a eu deux coups de
comptes en série mais on a montré les
images et elle jette ma maison vous
trouvez normal qu'une elle commet un
délit
elle a commise certainement un délit est
ce que ça justifie la violence des
policiers non nous sommes dans un état
de gros
d'ailleurs c'est le silence c'est les
violences policières qui crée sa propre
violence j'essaye de comprendre c'est
vous l'excusé en quelque sorte oui non
va faire alors là moi écoutez je vais
vous dire une chose est
à commencer bien cher que chaque
manifestation se termine comme elles le
sont c'est à dire que nous nous sommes
souvent des travailleurs et
travailleuses qui manifestons parce que
nous avons des indications qui me
semble-t-il sont légitimes et alors je
peux vous assurer que les professionnels
de la santé ont particulièrement des
revendications légitimes
ils ont passé des mois thierry bizot a
été exposée ils ont bien souvent
travaillé 13 heures par jour ils ont
risqué leur rien pour soigner la
population ils manifestent de manière
pacifique lors ce qu'ils aillent sur une
place ils se font gaz et nassez est
malmené par les forces de l'ordre qui
ont des consignes notamment du préfet
l'allmend pour que finalement les fêtes
de manifestations se terminent à la
viola je voulais qu'on reste sur ce cas
précis parce que c'est pour cela qu'on
vous a invité drissa tu sais vous voulez
interpellé madame verzeletti de la cgt
mais je trouve que c'est un cas qui est
un cas emblématique évidemment moi je
n'ai aucune
j'ai aucun doute sur les motivations de
cette dame lorsqu'elle arrive en
manifestation tarkkala des
revendications politiques très clair
après et la difficulté c'est qu'il ya
une certaine forme dans le grainage et
qu'elle est instrumentalisée par des
black block est en réalité et vous avez
la jurisprudence administrative
en réalité quand vous avez des exactions
vous demande de vous désolidarisez parce
que la réplique à l'est aussi forte à la
force doit rester à la loi
la réplique elle est aussi forte que les
cailloux les pavés et les projectiles
qui sont dans ces semaines madame merkel
et 6 qui vous dénoncez on l'a entendu
les violences policières et la manière
dont cette infirmière a été interpellé
est ce que vous regrettez et vous
dénoncez aussi les violences des black
blocks je rappelle que finalement
l'objet même de la manifestation à
savoir la revalorisation des personnels
hospitaliers a été totalement occulté
alors elle a été amputé notamment quand
même par les médias qui ont mis commun
parler
d'une partie des les médias sont
responsables de fait que la
manifestation a dégénéré
je n'ai pas dit cela j'ai dit que non
non je n'ai absolument pas dit ça ne me
fait pas d'eux mais je ne comprends pas
d'en vérifier quand même ce qui s'est
passé les manifestations souvent
finalement on assiste à de la glace dans
les manifestations parce que le maintien
de l'ordre n'est pas fait correctement
et le service d'ordre de la cgt
pourquoi pourquoi vous n'arrivez pas
vous à prendre en charge le maintien de
l'ordre puisqu'il la cgt a dans son
histoire un service d'ordre
non mais là ce que je vous explique ce
que des vingt personnes parce qu'on nous
avait expliqué qu'il y avait 100 ou 200
personnes des black blocs ce n'est pas
vraiment inquiété je ne les ai pas vus
est ce que vous dites est suranné mais
sinon non
est ce que vous demandez c'est en fait
c'est sinon vous n'êtes pas clair les
black blocks les options débreak dans
leur cheminement
moi ce que je vais vous dire ce que je
condamne d'être aujourd'hui je condamne
le maintien de l'ordre qui n'est pas
satisfaisant et je condamne
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre sur
ordre du préfet notamment dû prêter
l'allemagne et qui ordonne des lancers
du gazage qui ordonne des nas toutes les
manifestations oui vous pouvez dire que
c'est irresponsable ce qu'il est
responsable de nas et des personnes qui
manifestent de manière pacifique
ça s'est passé hier ça s'est passé
samedi dernier ça se passe quasiment à
chaque manifestation
vous avez des personnes des citoyens et
des citoyennes ils viennent manifester
c'est un droit fondamental et qui a
abandonné son coin c'est ne sont privés
de liberté on les menace alors qu'ils
n'ont commis aucun délit merci vraiment
venu manifester mais trajet dénoncé sur
le condamne merci madame verzeletti
d'être venu enfin d'avoir été en duplex
avec nous le mot de la fin pour une
enquête l on entend très clairement la
cgt au fond qui applaudit la libération
de cette femme et à ma question c'est on
est dans un face à face et on a
l'impression qu'on ne peut pas en sortir
si j'étais court derrière les françaises
soumises qui court derrière le
rassemblement national ils sont aussi
responsables
il porte atteinte à la république à
chacune de leurs expressions de la sorte
jusqu'où ça va aller
vous craignez escalade non faut que je
crois faut on en a hotel on en a quand
même vu pas mal en 2018 2019 donc je
crois qu'il faut pas laisser accroire
qu'on on va connaître des explosions
tous les sociale ou de cette violence
dans les semaines et mois à venir nous
politique on a une responsabilité
importante elle et de retisser le lien
il faut que les citoyennes et citoyens
aussi reprennent leurs rôles je dirais
d'acteurs de la démocratie voilà merci
merci à tous les deux est revenu sur le
plateau dell cp on va parler à présent
des personnes handicapées retour
d'expérience après 56 jours de
confinement
comment ont-elles vécu cette période
d'enfermement cette période d'isolement
qu'est ce qui a marché qu'est ce qui n'a
pas marché avant d'accueillir nos
invités voyez le reportage de maïté
frémont elle a recueilli le témoignage
de guillaume un jeune étudiant paralysé
reportage qu'il nomme de la mouche de 35
ans change d'âme actifs étudiants
membres d'une association créateur d'une
chaîne youtube
guillaume est atteint d'une paralysie
cérébrale qui limite ses déplacements
on peut ni marcher ni écrire mais même
mieux sol pour autant c'est un jeune
homme qui voit la vie du bon côté
lorsqu'on lui demande de raconter son
confinement il commence par les aspects
positifs que les musées soit ouvert dans
le monde entier via internet ont fait
pour les personnes handicapées ça nous
ferait un vrai vrai soulagement qu'on
n'a pas le reste de l'année
mais si vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
bouger parce que vous n'avez pas le
droit de bouger bah vous êtes mois en
situation de handicap que le rêve de la
dette de fait mais dans sa condition de
personnes dépendantes guillaume a subi
le confinement il ya une injection dont
on va le besoin qui c'est qui aurait dû
avoir lieu qu'en filmant qui n'a pas pu
avoir lieu
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à l'obtenir
pendant près de deux mois et demi jour
et nuit il a souffert physiquement
l'hôpital dont il dépend été débordés
par l'afflux de patients qu'aux vide et
guillaume ne pouvait donc pas recevoir
son injection
indispensable pour soulager sa douleur
de la toxine botulique délivrer
exclusivement à l'hôpital j'avais les
jambes hypertendus avec des gros
contraction je vous fais de la morphine
mais ce qui a été compliqué c'est que
dans les hôpitaux on n'avait pas il
n'avait pas plus d'informations que nous
sur ce qu'on a le droit de faire revenir
ou pas des patients qui ne sont pas
devenus aujourd'hui des confiné
guillaume un message à faire passer à
sophie cluzel la question mon
interrogation c'est comment est ce que
pour l'année pour si jamais cessé
pandémie devait revenir
comment mieux collaborer entre patients
personnes handicapées et professionnels
libéraux afin de soulager les systèmes
hospitaliers
bonsoir sophie cluzel soirée merci
infiniment d'être sur ce plateau sur lcp
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
d'état en charge des personnes
handicapées vous allez tout de suite
répondre à guillaume
mais je présente d'abord jérémie boroy
bonsoir merci d'être là
vous présidez le comité national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
vous êtes accompagné ce soir d'un
interprète qui va traduire en langue des
signes
notre discussion car vous êtes sourd de
naissance alors déjà on va répondre à
guillaume guillaume pose une question
très concrète la difficulté d'accès aux
soins
que l'on soit d'ailleurs handicapés ou
pas c'était compliqué d'accéder aux
soins
quand il ne s'agissait pas du coc vide
dans notre pays et particulièrement en
ile de france
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez il n'a pas pu être soignées
normalement pendant le confinement
d'abord je le salue guillaume parce que
je le connais bien on nous avons
travaillé ensemble
il a tout à fait raison c'est ce qui
nous a alerté le plus c'est cette
rupture de soins pour des personnes en
situation de handicap qui en avaient
besoin d perte d'acquis important que ce
soit en kiné en psychomotricité ou en
soins infirmiers c'est pour ça que nous
avons voulu tout de suite lancé ce
numéro 2 on en reparlera 0 800 363 160
pour répondre à cet accès aux soins qui
devait être mis en place alors s'il ya
une deuxième vague parce que c'est la
caste de guillaume il veut être sûr
qu'il sera soigné s'il n'y a plus de
place à l'hôpital
il veut qu'un médecin de ville ou que un
médecin aux cliniques puissent le
recevoir et le soigner lui donner son
traitement et bien c'est ça que nous
voulons
c'est pouvoir m guillaume en relation
avec ces professionnels parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le parcours du
combattant
si l'hôpital vous dit non vous vous
tourner vers qui trois français sur cinq
n'ont pas de médecin soignant
aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent prendre le
relais et avec cette justement ce numéro
que nous voulons mettre en place et que
nous avons lancé il ya huit jours plus
de 100 appels par jour 1 déjà alors que
justement il n'a pas bénéficié d'une
grande promotion parce que nous voulions
monter en puissance vous avez en séries
mais la mise en oeuvre à cause de la
crise n est exact de ce numéro vert pour
3,7 pour 3 vraiment trois raisons
principales la problématique de l'accès
aux soins comme le dit très bien
guillaume comment je peux solliciter mon
réseau de proximité qui est fort pas
forcément formés comment je mets en
place par exemple de la spécialisation à
domicile pour éviter justement cette
absence de soins comme enjeu mais un
médecin de ville en connaissance des
besoins spécifiques d'une personne en
situation de handicap parce que le soin
à l'hôpital n'est plus possible mais
aussi le répit pour les aidants qu'ils
sont épuisés au bout de deux mois deux
mois et demi trois mois voilà donc tout
ça on va en parler à ce pour répondre
aux besoins de guillaume avant tout des
aidants j'aimerais avec vous jérémie
boroy qu'on essaye de faire un retour
d'expérience alors évidemment les
situations sont très différentes mais en
même temps de quoi selon vous et d'après
vos remontées de terrain
cette crise sanitaire a été le
révélateur pour les personnes
handicapées elle a été le révélateur de
la demande très portent de longues
jambes des personnes quel que soit leur
handicap quelles que soient les
contraintes qu'elles rencontrent des
traités comme n'importe qui tu es bien
maman takyro sortie donc ces
interpellations à accéder au droit
commun elle était un peu occulté passé
dans la mobilisation de tous les acteurs
lors qu'on est rentré en confinement que
ce soit les acteurs publics les acteurs
associatifs des acteurs locaux et même
les personnes elles-mêmes concernés pour
que deux fois d'abord les dispositifs de
droit commun qu'il faut à la portée de
toutes les pertes hier c'est en fonction
des besoins en fonction des handicaps en
fonction des contraintes en fonction des
préférences en fonction des uns des
craintes des uns et des autres l'acte et
au télétravail lacteo au service public
l'acte et à la continuité pédagogique a
pu être différent en fonction des
enfants sont nés cas l'impact
psychologique
quand on est déjà souvent isolés il faut
le dire quand on souffre d'un handicap
et qu'on se retrouve enfermé quel est il
il ya plus d'anxiété plus de stress de
nervosité
il ya vraiment de tout je vous dis
paradoxalement des témoignages de
personnes qui devaient finalement le
continent c'est rt proche qu'on était
déjà et puis le handicap a fait que on a
dû depuis très longtemps à prendre à
tous les brevets apprend d'être autonome
apprendre à faire face à l'imprévu
apprendre la tôle cité l'aide ici ou là
et le confinement pour certains noms ne
va pas changer grand chose vous par
exemple à moins ce que j'ai constaté
c'était surtout que tu écris finalement
elle a accéléré les réponses et
d'accessibilité qu'on attendait depuis
longtemps
certaines étaient déjà en place le fait
de voir le président de la république
d'haïti thématiquement interprète en
langue des signes est sous titré lors de
ses interventions le voir les points
presse du directeur général de la santé
interprétant du yachting de voir que
l'application un top cow vide a été
conçu dès le départ pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins des utilisateurs et
handicapées ont les même jusqu à les
concevoir le mode d'emploi empathie la
lire et à comprendre pour que les
personnes puissent faire le choix de
télécharger l'application nous le
fassions totalement écrit donc vous
voyez il ya encore plein de penser à
vous pour prendre un exemple très
concret le port du masque quand on est
sourd alors ça là c'est plus compliqué
vous êtes au supermarché
nous vous touchez caissière vous ne
pouvez pas la comprendre le port du
masque pour les personnes sourdes mais
pas seulement pour d'autres personnes
aussi qu'ils sont habitués plutôt à
tapis et je les repère visuel pour
communiquer c'est une contrainte pour
d'autres que le fait de porter un mac
qui est contraignant lors je pense qu'il
ya eu de façon habile des réactions très
rapide pour que la contrainte fois
limité dans certains cas mais ça montre
bien que l'on doit aller vers
l'homologation de mac adapté pour que si
jamais nous devons en prolonger le port
de semak les personnes ne plus
communiquer plus facilement avec
notamment du mac avec une fenêtre 30 40
on sait 3 que deux modèles sont en cours
les homologations sont en cours
on parlait voilà de l'impact
psychologique on sait que pour les
enfants ils ont été prioritaires bon ça
ça a plutôt marché voulait dire ça comme
ça de bilan plutôt positif
la reprise de l'école en tout cas a été
en effet un public cible prioritaire
pour limiter justement les perte
d'acquis là nous sommes en train de
rouvrir les externats donc les soixante
mille enfants qui sont revenus chez eux
vont reprendre le chemin des externats
un des établissements
ils ont déjà repris sur man d'école
parce qu'avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale nous en avons fait une
priorité
il ré ouvre aussi petit à petit toutes
les visites avec les internats mais pour
autant la reprise je dirais dans une vie
ordinaire elle va être plus compliqué
encore plus longue que pour le citoyen
lambda pourquoi et bien parce que tout a
été bousculé et donc justement vous
l'avais dit il ya eu des pertes de soins
il ya eu des problématiques des dents
qui ne veulent pas par crainte de
remettre leur temps leurs enfants ou
leurs à douze dans un état bizarre on y
va sur les et autant sont épuisés ils
sont épuisés parce qu'évidemment d'abord
il s'occupe
oui ça a été non stop de leur famille de
leur père à moi avec hélas la charge est
devenu l'art car supportable donc il
nous faut avoir du relayage du répit sur
les appels qu'on a on ne s'est pas
trompé c'est vraiment ça qui nous
demande du répit j'avais par exemple une
maman qui est un enfant de 8 ans qui a
télé fait beaucoup trop télétravail il
est obligé de reprendre pour autant elle
a du mal à le faire garder son enfant et
puis cet été
eh bien il faudra qu'elle rattrape ses
heures et cet été elle a pas de solution
eh bien nous vous voyez une équipe
reléguée h qui va venir à domicile et
qui va les accompagner l'enfant au
centre de loisirs pour qu'on comprenne
comment fonctionne cet enfant et qu'ils
puissent être accueillis
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on met en place
les solutions de répit à travers ce
numéro c'est un numéro national mais
avec des réponses de proximité dans les
terrains parce que moi c'est remettre
aux énormes où elle prendre un peu de
temps pour exactement après voilà 56
jours de confinement jérémy leroy vous
vous disiez au fond on se rend compte
que ça a accéléré l'accessibilité il ya
des choses qui sont en cours le monde
d'après pour les personnes handicapées
comment vous le voyez qu'est ce que vous
attendez le monde d'après je vois ta
culpabilité qu'on a un peu accéléré
pierre une idée confortée augmentée vous
est donnée de l'exemple de
d'accessibilité qu'on avait vu notamment
sur les méthodes d'information ogden moi
je souhaite que monde après tout choix
et bien
chaque ministre chaque chaque élu chaque
assemblée comme l'assemblée nationale le
sénat
le c2 chaque parlementaire chaque
formation politique qui prenne en charge
sa propre activité pour que et bien tous
les citoyen quelques toiles aux
contraintes puisque partie du pays au
débat le monde d'après c'est en
numérique réellement accessible aux
canuts mérite éventuellement
l'accessibilité pour les personnes qui
ne boit pas aucune entente à l'ophite
l'équipement de tous les français c'est
la possibilité d'accéder donc au
télétravail au service public at est à
même de continuité pédagogique et jeu je
me dis que on a encore un chanteur
ouvrir pour que dans l'hypothèse où deux
oreillons nour conflits nés et bien on
tient compte des conséquences de
confinement est passé pour que l'on
puisse traiter à domicile le plus
longtemps possible et conflits
continuels donc de travailler de
s'informer et de se former
ça fait le mandat et dresse aussi le
télétravail sur lequel nous
réfléchissons beaucoup d'un télétravail
choisi est pas subi un télétravail
accompagner là aussi nous avons des
grandes grandes voies d'amélioration ce
sont des téléconsultations parce que
nous les avons mis tout de suite en
place rembourser très innovant
téléconsultation sur sur des métiers
qu'ils n'étaient pas en téléconsultation
comme de l'ergot comme de la psychologue
il faut qu'on réfléchisse à sa charge de
travail pour les personnes handicapées
ceux qui sont actifs
évidemment pour certains d'entre eux ont
été mises au chômage partiel vous ne
craignez pas des abus je me disais
qu'ils ont peur de retrouver leur emploi
je mobilise largement les les
entreprises gt1 rajiv pour mobiliser
justement les hôteliers les cafetiers
parce que il ya beaucoup d'emplois dans
ces métiers là je mobilise l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales et
patronales pour qu'elles soient
vigilantes que dans le dialogue social
justement les personnes handicapées ne
subissent pas une désinsertion
professionnelle massive parce que c'est
la crainte de beaucoup
donc nous sommes en demande accompagnant
nous avons mobilisé pôle emploi cap
emploi je mobilise l'ensemble des
signataires de la charte de la manif du
char tu manifestes inclusion pour que
les entreprises ne va pas ça l'acte
elles ont signé des engagements il faut
qu'elle passe à l'acte et qu'elles
respectent leurs engagements sociétaux
ça c'est très un prêt à cela on va
rappeler le numéro vert et un cinquième
risque aussi qui a été votée ici à
l'assemblée nationale sur la dépendance
mais qui concerne l'autonomie handicapés
l'autonomie alors le numéro vert on le
voit à l'écran 0 800 300
soixante 360 merci infiniment vous
restez avec nous jérémy bauwin on va
faire un petit tour par l'assemblée
nationale c'est de retrouver thomas des
prêts pour sa chronique ma journée à
l'assemblée il nous raconte ce soit les
coulisses d'un déconfinement très
attendu celui des députés où exactement
myriam à partir de lundi l'assemblée
nationale se dé confine un peu plus
encore je vous raconte tout ça c'est ma
journée à l'assemblée
[Musique]
vous savez l'assemblée nationale a elle
aussi été touchée par l'épidémie de
coronavirus c'était même l'un des foyers
épidémiques de france avec près de 20
députés contaminés et ici aussi il ya eu
des mesures de confinement des députés
pour les séances de questions au
gouvernement puis 28 75 et maintenant
150 et à partir de lundi ils seront de
nouveau 577 à pouvoir siéger
c'est une très bonne nouvelle je pense
qu'on l'attendait tous parce que nous
étions un peu à bout des
visioconférences
on a tous envie de reprendre le travail
exactement comme avant que la
controverse politique puisse reprendre
toute sa place pouvoir échanger de vive
voix en face à face avec ses collègues
cette importance est essentiel je crois
dans tous les milieux de la société y
compris au parlement
alors concrètement ce retour des 577
députés se fera sous conditions il
faudra parfois porter un masque
écoutez ce qu'en dit sylvain waserman un
des vice-présidents de l'assemblée
nationale à partir de la semaine
prochaine comment ça va se passer
alors en tant que vice président de
l'assemblée en étant au perchoir la
semaine prochaine j'aurais effectivement
à décider au cas par cas si la présence
nécessite pas le port du masque
après je crois je fais tout à fait
confiance dans mes collègues pour nous
aider à prendre les meilleures décisions
il est évidemment pas question de
prendre des risques par rapport aux
gestes barrières donc nous ferons en
bonne intelligence et sas et trans
partisan nous serons à trouver nos
marques
pendant cette période même si le
parlement a continué de travailler sans
interruption certains dénoncent un
affaiblissement de la démocratie
les mois que nous on vivre c'était quand
même
un parlement aux karkwa pour quelqu'un
qui tient la scène dans une démocratie
parlementaire c'est c'est pas tenable
longtemps
heureusement que la présidence de la
république continue à fonctionner que
les ministères continuent à fonctionner
mais curieusement le législatif le
contre-pouvoir lui a été quand même un
peu tenu à l'écart c'est totalement faux
et on peut être très très fier en france
parce qu'on est le parlement d'europe
qui a le plus travaillé pendant la
période de continent non seulement nous
avons pu légiférer et puis surtout nous
avons maintenu les questions
gouvernement donc chaque semaine de
façon hebdomadaire
ce qui est inédit en europe donc franck
au contraire on peut être très fier je
vois la mairie mais pour être tout à
fait complet le président de l'assemblée
nationale richard ferrand a mis en place
un groupe de travail pour préparer une
éventuelle autre crise mais ça on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans ma journée
à l'assemblée
merci thomas sophie cluzel qu'est-ce que
vous garderez comme souvenir de cette
période si étrange d'un parlement
confiné à bouger danger continue à
travailler avec eux parce que j'ai créé
une visio avec l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires chacun âme à désigner un
référent dans chaque groupe
parlementaire pour tenez tenir informé
de tout ce qu'on faisait
le seul qui a répondu absences et les
filles bizarrement ai dit que c'est
compliqué mais il n'est pas venu
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya des façons
différentes de maintenir la démocratie
nous l'avons maintenu ce dialogue
toutes les semaines j'avais une vision
avec les députés avec les sénateurs de
tous les groupes mais rien ne remplace
la femme le contact physique merci
infiniment va retrouver à présent notre
franco britannique préféré pour sa
chronique du mercredi j'ai nommé alex
taylor
alors alex demain emmanuel macron va se
rendre à londres pour le 80e
anniversaire de l'appel du 18 juin sur
fond de polémique sur la statue de
winston churchill qu'on a été obligés
d'en bal et je crois c'est ça bonjour
mais rien oui c'est vrai que cette
statue a focalisé depuis une semaine les
débats dans le cadre de blacklight
matters certains prétendant que
churchill était raciste c'est vrai que
si on veut prouver sa l'épreuve non pas
comme quoi ils n'étaient pas très
politically correct mais c'est sûr qu'il
faut le remettre dans le contexte
historique mais même à l'époque certains
considérés comme étant très
réactionnaire en 37 par exemple il se
félicita qu'un peuple supérieur on place
les peuples indigènes en australie où
états unis il dénonça les indiens les
palestiniens comme les hordes de
barbares je cite ont marqué ces mêmes
mots pour les allemands qui étaient des
hordes barbares prusse seul à dire en sa
faveur on peut rappeler que qui
contribuera beaucoup quand même à la
défaite du plus gros racistes de tous
les temps alors ce week-end des hordes
de l'extrême droite sont arrivés à
londres soit disant pour protéger le dit
churchill contre les blacks live matters
seul hic les black clouds matters ne
sont pas venus dans les 16 autres
personnes présentes c'était la police on
a vu des scènes donc où les gens
d'extrême droite faisait le salut nazi
pour défendre churchill
donc c'est la plus parfaite dystopie
s'il en est et boris johnson a signé un
article parlant de churchill dans le
telegraph lundi
faut dire mais rien que johnson écrit
des articles sur churchill chaque
semaine dans deux séries car c'est un
peu son totem là il se dit outré que
l'on veuille photoshopée les heures les
plus glorieuses de l'histoire
britannique faudrait un peu pour
détourner le débat parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de gens grand beau temps qui
réclame vraiment qu'on fasse disparaître
cette statue or demain arrive le
président marc rossi toutefois les
douanes britanniques le laisse passer le
dispense de quarantaine le maire de
l'andi qui la femme expectations une
attente très très ferme comme quoi la
statue soit disant ballet faut dire pour
finir que tu cherchais d'être en bonne
compagnie gonzi et membre de la aussi
devant le parlement britannique sont
actuellement protégés accusés à leur
tour d'incorporer et oui le racisme
vivons une drôle d'époque quelque part
en quarantaine entre dystopie et utopie
merci beaucoup alex je signale que vous
aussi vous avez une petite statue sur
votre cheminée et j'adore la manière
dont vous l'avez en bas les c'est fini
allez on va parler maintenant comme tous
les x du monde d'après le jour d'après
c'est un entretien passionnant que je
vous propose de découvrir ce soir sur
notre système immunitaire figurez vous
qu'on aille
mémoire immunitaire c'est le professeur
jean claude weil à l'hôpital necker qui
va nous expliquer tout cela regarde
[Musique]
bonjour jean claude weill et merci
d'être là vous êtes professeur
d'immunologie à l'hôpital necker enfants
malades et membre de l'académie des
sciences vous êtes un spécialiste de ce
qu'on appelle la mémoire immunitaire
pourquoi certains fabrique des anticorps
pourquoi d'autres sont protégés et ceux
qu vite 19 pose des questions
innombrables en matière d'immunité
individuelle collective pour faire
simple qu'est ce que le système
immunitaire
alors pour faire très simple dans la
moelle osseuse tous les jours on produit
5 milliards en gros de cellules il ya 5
milliards de cellules qui sortent de la
moelle osseuse qui sont les cellules du
système immunitaire csn unitaires sont
censés avoir des systèmes de
reconnaissance qui leur permet chacune
deux façons différentes de reconnaître
un objet différent un pathogènes
différents un virus différents donc le
principe c'est une multitude de cellules
dans le sang et dans les organes
lymphoïdes qui se promènent qui
circulent qu'ils font qui scanne un peu
comme des comme des motards qui scanne
constamment le périphérique
quand il reconnaît quelque chose
d'étranger
cette cellule qui le reconnaît puisque
tout reconnaît la différence cette
cellule reconnaît cet étrange hélas
hélas il est censé se met en mouvement
bon nous protéger contre cette étrange
et il ya des anticorps qui reconnaissent
il y en a certains qui non seulement
reconnaissent mais qui attrape le corps
étranger et le neutre années qui font
barrière donc quel motard qui met à pv
ya le motard qui met des menottes et qui
se débarrasse de la personne qui
pourrait produire des dangers et pour le
coc vie de 19 ce nouveau virus
coronavirus caisse concert matière
d'immunité
sinon on est contaminé on fabrique des
anticorps qui nous plongeait pour
répondre à votre question tout de suite
s'appelle la séroconversion dès qu'un
virus rentrons un pathogène grand dans
l'organisme comme le hiv comme le sida
ont fait une séroconversion pour le sida
c'est comme ça qu'on teste infecte ivité
des gens ils ont un anticorps qui a
reconnu le virus qui rentraient dans
leur organisme
mais si cet anticorps ne fait pas partie
des anticorps neutralisants c'est juste
un test que ces gens ont rencontré le
virus s'appelle la séroconversion celle
anticorps neutralisants qui protège ses
l'anticorps tout cours spécifiques du
virus qui marque la séroconversion qui
marque que vous avez rencontré le virus
c'est pas la même chose où tous les gens
qui vont rencontrer font une
séroconversion est ce qu ils font tous
des anticorps neutralisants c'est la
question et les enfants c'est vrai que
ça surprend dans cette épidémie est ce
que ils sont immunisés
parce qu'ils ont été vaccinées où il
aurait rencontré des virus similaire
dans la petite enfance c'est une
question compliquée sur les enfants on a
l'impression peut-être le récepteur est
un peu moins présent au niveau des
cellules au niveau des cellules
pulmonaires des pneus aux sites qui sont
là si la première cible du virus on a
l'impression que du fait que les enfants
sont polis vacciner quand même et qu'ils
rencontrent dans la crèche partout à
l'école énormément de pathogènes
ils ont ce qu'on appelle une immunité
innée très américaine saturn hymne il
n'était muni t il ont une immunité innée
qui ne sont pas les lymphocytes t ou b
c'est encore une autre immunité qui est
très renforcée et qui pourrait les
protéger est ce qu'il y à une immunité
après une contamination du col et 19
alors les résultats qu'on a mais on n'a
pas de résultats sur le long gît tu
zinal puisque le veulent de cette
maladie n'existe que depuis deux mois et
demi on peut pas aller plus loin ça on a
des résultats sur le co vide de 2003 on
a des résultats sur les macaques qui
sont un très bon modèle et on a
l'impression que ce virus
je vais encore utiliser un terme
technique et très immunogène c'est à
dire qu'il déclenche une très bonne
réponse immunitaire et au niveau des
anticorps neutralisants on a
l'impression que la plupart des gens les
fonds et font aussi des cellules la
mémoire qui qui pourront eux aussi
produire donc la première réponse est
oui la longévité de cette réponse qu'est
ce que dans six mois dans un an dans
deux ans on sera encore protégés nobody
knows comme audi en tête l immunité
individuelle de chacun d'entre nous et
l'immunité de groupe on a beaucoup
entendu dire depuis le début de
l'épidémie que si à peu près la moitié
ou plus je ne sais pas de la population
était et est avait contracté le virus
elles seraient immunisés
c'est le pari qu'ont fait certains pays
comme la suède par exemple oui mais paye
cher pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui par habitant le poussera le
plus gros taux d'infection en europe en
ayant choisi de ne pas de ne pas confiné
qui payent très cher ça ne marche pas le
mythe et le groupe limited groupe il
faut qu' il faut que 60 à 75 % des gens
sont un peu soi et été infectés
s'appelle heures d'immunité les
idéologies ça peut limiter troupeau
c'est à dire que si 75% des gens sont
infectés et qu'ils ont fait des
anticorps neutralisants ça veut dire que
ça veut dire que si le virus
si le virus se balader revient ils vont
neutraliser immédiatement donc ils vont
jamais ils vont jamais le transférer
donc on peut imaginer qu'à ce taux de
protection de la population
le virus ne ne pourra plus se propager
parce qu'il peut pas rester plus de
quelques heures chez un individu sans
être neutralisé la vie humaine est
forcément beaucoup plus on est à 30 ans
à peu près trente mille morts en france
si on n'avait pas fait le confinement si
on n'avait pas mis les mesures de
distanciation le masque et tout je pense
qu'on aurait dès qu'on avait décidé
qu'il fallait que les gens s'infecte les
uns les autres on serait à combien on
aurait pu avoir trois cent mille membres
oui c'est ce que c'est des prévisions
toujours parle aussi d immunité croiser
les must-see que ça veut dire ça ça veut
dire que si vous avez rencontré un virus
le corona virus saisonniers qui produit
des rhumes ou le coronavirus de le
premier de 2003 et que vous aviez vous
avez fait une réponse immunitaire
disons avec des anticorps et si ces
anticorps reconnaît 5 également un petit
peu le nouveau virus
on appelle sa crosse réactive ils sont
cons ces nuitées croisés ils
reconnaissent le premier et
reconnaissent un peu le deuxième
donc il pourrait vous protéger contre le
deuxième on a l'impression que les
coronavirus saisonniers ont peut-être
des similitudes suffisante avec le
nouveau pour avoir chez certaines
personnes
créé cette protection croisée les
saisonniers ou pas ce virus on le sait
ou pas celui celui qui semble
progressivement maîtrisé
arrête ans ancien c'est le problème de
la des problèmes de la deuxième vague
est ce qu'elle aura lieu en automne
est-ce qu'en général quand on s'approche
de l'été il ya une chute des infections
virales comme de la grille pour quoi et
ça repart dans une saison plus froides
on ne sait rien sur le copier la
question de la deuxième vague est
totalement ouvert ce qu'on ne sait rien
est-ce que ce qui frappe c'est qu'on ne
fait rien depuis le début puisque
c'était à nouveau virus deux mois et
demi après on ne sait toujours rien moi
c'est vraiment pas du tout parce que ça
fait longtemps que je fais de la
recherche et je sais toujours rien sur
le sujet sur lequel je travaille donc
pour les chercheurs de rien savoir c'est
le quotidien
on a quand même appris se tromper à tous
les coups sur le quotidien la
transmission il est très tard au lycée
on a vu qu'il est 36 fois plus en gros
transmissibles que le virus de la grippe
mais il atteint pas les chiffres de la
rougeole vous en tant que moi oui
immunologue quelles sont les questions
quelles sont les questions qui vous
taraude le plus sur ce que vivent 19
il y avait une question qui me taraude
aime et qui n'apportera rien si telle
est la question que les épidémiologistes
amant les brillants éthologistes de
pasteur a fait des projections à partir
de ce bateau le diamant une princesse on
l'avait de les 700 personnes du bateau x
qu'ils étaient infectés il ce qui était
à symptomatique
il avait fait une projection avec une
marge d'erreur énorme en disant qu entre
deux et sept et demi pour cent de la
population française étaient infectées
sans le savoir un symptomatique
mais ça m'intrigue beaucoup ça veut dire
quatre à cinq millions de personnes
auraient été infectées sans sans le
savoir en gros nez en tout c'est pendant
trois jours et tout une question qui
m'intrigue est ce que vraiment dit pas
vous semble trop important comme siffler
je peux pas me répond je suis
incompétent les uns symptomatique on
n'en a pas parlé
les voir ils sont immunisés mais comme
des enfants dont ils ont ils sont
porteront pas malade mais ils ont été
infectées mais ils n'ont ils n'ont pas
fait de ils sont restés chez eux où ils
étaient un petit peu ils ont un peu
tousser au coin mais ils n'ont pas fait
de longs ils n'ont rien déclarer sur le
plan clinique
et ça là encore on ne peut pas
l'expliquer à ce stade on a l'impression
on l'a quand même l'impression que les
jeunes que les jeunes notamment le
personnel soignant parce que ça c'est un
très bon exemple personnel soignant a
été très affectés dans les hôpitaux le
personnel soignant était infecté des
gens de 25
trente ans qui ont fait ce travail
fantastique on a l'impression qu'ils ont
fait très peu ils sont restés chez eux
deux semaines y en a qui y en a qui ont
eu un peu de fièvre mais ils n'ont
jamais été hospitalisé oxygénée ni henri
animaux et les pistes de réponses c'est
l'âge de la jeunesse l'âge c'est le truc
majeur les gens âgés auld à 65 ans et
surtout les commodités obésité maladies
cardiovasculaires le chercheur que vous
êtes
qui sait à combien le temps de la
recherche et le temps de la science et
l'on est en décalage avec celui du soin
et avec celui d'urgence ça le met dans
quel état d'esprit ça vous ça vous agace
à vous enrage que ce soit si long ou la
sagesse du scientifique l'emportent
il faut attendre il va falloir encore
attendre nous ce qu'on sait en tant que
chercheur ça me fait penser à des choses
de l'actualité donc on va peut-être dont
va pas parler parce qu'on en parle trop
mais que les chercheurs sont légitimes a
tenté tout ce qu'ils aient tous qu'il
faut tenter
donc on ne peut pas reprocher un
chercheur de tenter telles pistes tel
médicament telles combinaisons notamment
ça fait partie du travail prend beaucoup
de temps ces noms soient tout de suite
soit sur le long terme mais dans 95% des
cas l'équipe de chercheurs se trompent
ça serait si on faisait une découverte
par semaine presque toujours ça marche
pas ce qu'on fait c'est pas grave on
passe à autre chose c'est tout c'est
comme ça merci beaucoup
vous en paierez jean claude weil
[Musique]
voilà on va s'arrêter là sur le temps
long de la recherche merci de nous avoir
suivis tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire avec jean pierre graff y en
à demain
[Musique]